bond any thug can kill  i have to know i can trust you  [Music]  well i understand double those have a  very short life expectancy  you are a kite dancing in a hurricane mr  bond  is this really what you want  always alone  [Music]  we used to be able to get into a room  with the enemy  now they're just floating in the ether  when our secret finds its way out it'll  be the death of you  oh my god target enough people  remember the people become the weapon  who is he james  you don't know what this is  james want  license to kill  in love with madeleine swann  i could be speaking to my own reflection  only your skills die with your body  and life is all about leaving something  behind  isn't it  come on bond where the hell are you  tank  okay  if we don't do this  there will be nothing left to say  i have to finish this  nope  [Music]  you